[Musique]
en rouge château fort en bleu Toussus le
Noble un objectif
7817 qui n'est autre que le code postal
que ce partage à château fort est touché
le noble
qui en est digne pour se départager les
deux communes se sont affrontées autour
des preuves sportives une chose est sûre
les équipes mères en tête étaient
motivées il y a la façon de voir les
choses et on va réfléchir on dira ça à
la fin si on les a laissé gagner parce
que il nous accueillait ou si parce
qu'ils étaient meilleurs
aujourd'hui on se partage le code postal
à la suite de 7 ou 8 jeux d'équipe et
que le meilleur gagne
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons nous battre pour
le code postal Patrice révélation
les épreuves sont lancées
et se joue par catégorie d'âge ils sont
une soixantaine à avoir souhaité en
découdre à croire en leur équipe et en
leur village
tous les avantages l'avantage
psychologique et l'avantage de la force
à ce que les villages font des choses
ensemble dans Shadow fort il y a
beaucoup d'activités dans tous aussi je
trouvais que c'était vraiment
sympathique on est compétitive et qu'on
veut gagner c'est important et qu'en
plus bah ils ont pris du temps à
l'organiser alors c'est important que ça
soit qu'il y a du monde on est trop fort
à côté
c'est château fort quoi
non mais nous c'est tous sûr euh là on
est à tous eu donc c'est normal qu'il y
a plein de habitants qui vont venir pour
soutenir l'équipe quoi parce que nous on
a des avions ils n'en ont pas
nous on vole on glisse on est uni bon
après je les connais pas hein mais moi
je pense qu'il n'y a aucun doute sur le
fait qu'on gagne tir à la corde cours
son sac glisse ce qui voici
quelques-unes des épreuves une ambiance
bon enfant avec un but solidaire une
tombola permet de récolter des fonds
pour des chiens guides d'aveugles mon
chien que vous voyez ici est le millième
chien qui a été formé et confié par
l'association à des malvoyants je dis
toujours il m'a rajeuni de 10 ans c'est
à dire que
là il y a le côté
gain d'autonomie gain enfin que tout le
monde peut imaginer un chien guide ça
vous guide comme son nom l'indique il y
a aussi le côté le dans le regard des
autres
vous vous n'êtes pas avec une canne
blanche et les gens oublient que vous
êtes malvoyants ou aveugle après trois
heures d'épreuve les Bleus s'inclinent
château fort remporte cette première
édition de jeu intervillages la revanche
ce sera l'an prochain dans la ville
gagnante